well here we are
[Music]
again
so BBC me decided to mess with me again
I wasn't intending to devote a video on
this but honestly this is different
enough from the last very recent time
they decided to do stuff with it well I
say decided here's the thing this is
distinctly different from the last time
I had trouble with the BBC and
ultimately the point of this video is
not to be grousing about that though I
am going to do that the main purpose of
this video is actually to explain why my
review for the Doctor Who special wild
blue yonder is currently in the state
that it's in and why it will remain so
here on YouTube um so if you saw that
review within the first three three and
a/ half weeks that went up
congratulations you saw the review as it
was intended you watch it now it's uh
it's going to be a little rougher a
little choppier some thoughts are going
to seem incomplete or it's going to seem
like I jump topics uh out of nowhere and
uh it's going to be visually a lot less
interesting here's why that happened so
the BBC claimed uh footage from the
episode wild blue yonder on that video
now this is different from what happened
with my review on uh the star Beast
there's the video where I talked about
everything that went on there but long
story made short that one was actually
blocked and by every indication that I
can tell the what happened there and I
can't be 100% certain about this cuz you
can't actually get a hold of anybody
involved but the way that it happened
the way that it ultimately resolved to
me says um that it got blocked by
accident and it was resolved fairly
quickly because it got blocked on the
basis of having footage from the giggle
which obviously it didn't that episode
hadn't aired yet but they ended up
claiming just part of the credits that I
showed when I was praising the
credits so the thing was that I'm fairly
positive what happened was they had
uploaded the giggle into uh YouTube's
copyright system and said if you find
footage from this block it and probably
in an effort to stamp out any potential
leaks of the episode early unfortunately
that would have had the opening credits
in it so when I saw I had some of the
opening credits in something that had
been fed in in into YouTube system
saying block this if you see it suddenly
my video was blocked now as I said I did
get that resolved and that was um
partially due to um not fully thinking
through what they were doing on the part
of the BBC because they should have
clipped out the credits uh to avoid that
kind of issue but also just because of
the broad sord approach that YouTube
system has towards these things but that
was resolved this was different this was
a claim on every single bit of footage
that I used and it wasn't a block they
were claiming it and taking the revenue
so the difference is nobody suddenly
couldn't get access to it but suddenly
the money that it was making wasn't
going to me it was going to the
BBC now BBC has claimed stuff uh and
claimed revenue from me before in the
past and not resolved it on a uh appeal
which I also did he and they denied now
the last time this happened to be was
God I don't know four years ago three
four years ago something like that and
that was on a video that actually wasn't
even about Doctor Who but I brought up
uh some stuff regarding bill and they
claimed it because of the footage it was
a very small percentage of the video but
they did it anyways now the thing in
that case was I knew the problem was
because the clip I used was too long
general rule of thumb and this has
served me well for a long time with the
BBC is if an individual clip is under 10
seconds they leave you alone now that's
not a legal thing that's not a case of
if it's under 10 seconds they are not
allowed to copyright claim you no they
are
but as a general rule most copyright
holders I find most of the large
business IP holders at any rate if it's
under 10 seconds any given clip they've
set up the uh Bots to ignore it and
that's been the case with the BBC and
that's worked for me for a long time but
here they didn't just claim long Clips
because first of all I didn't have
anything over 10 seconds I make a point
of not using anything over 10 seconds
but they claimed it anyways and it
wasn't just one thing it was everything
everything now I have no way of knowing
if this was done manually if this was an
autom uh something done by accident as
part of an automatic system I will never
be able to know all I know is that they
claimed huge swads of the video and were
taking the revenue from it and denied my
appeal now I could have taken it further
I could have disputed it but the thing
is if they didn't give in that uh and I
talked about this in the video about the
last time if I if they didn't give into
that that could have meant a copyright
strike um against me and I would have
had to have been prepared to actually go
to court over it which I cannot afford
to
do so I had to back off and start
trimming it
because you can just upload a whole new
version of the video but because they
were claiming everything and not just
one thing it seemed like okay well and
not to mention if you do that it you get
rid of your old want upload a new one
the views the comments Etc they don't
carry over you have wiped out whatever
you originally put up on there so I
didn't want to do that and I went and I
started
trimming what I realized um
unfortunately was initially like I
trimmed this cool they claimed another
part trim that claimed another part
claim claim claim claim claim claim and
eventually I realized I just had to cut
out virtually every moment in which I
had any footage whatsoever from the
episode now this is where the jankiness
of YouTube itself enters the picture
because YouTube's uh sort of backend uh
tools that you can use to do some minor
edits to your video they're not
especially sophisticated I don't
necessarily expect them to be as
sophisticated as like my editing Suite
that I use but there's a very basic
simple thing that could have solved a
lot of problems
here when you're editing a video that's
already been uploaded to YouTube system
on their back end which is what you have
to do to trim stuff out and not lose
comments views Etc um there was a trim
tool to cut stuff out even though the
system registers and can tell the
difference between an audio and a video
track you cannot edit those separately
the reason that matters here is because
most of the clips that I used were not
just a clip inserted there were a couple
of those where I wanted to like show the
line reading or something that I was
referring to but most of it was me
showing the moment as I described it
meaning the audio was me but the video
was from uh that episode of Doctor Who
and if YouTube allowed you to edit the
video and audio track separately I could
have just cut the video out it would
have been black for the course of that
which wouldn't have been good but it
would have left the points that I made
and the things that I said intact and so
the end result wouldn't be a jumbled
mess it would just have some visual
blanks but YouTube doesn't let you edit
those separately so my only option was
to cut it all out so that's why the
video is in the current state that it is
it is still possible to see the full
video but I have had to opt to make that
a patreon
exclusive which I've never had to do
before I've never had to do an edit like
this and then put the actual original
intended version of the video only
available on patreon because patreon now
has it where you can upload full videos
there you used to like a couple years
ago only be able to link to videos
uploaded elsewhere that's not the case
so I uploaded the entire thing to
patreon and my supporters there at any
tier can see the whole thing and it
really ticks me off because I make a
point of not
gatekeeping uh or pay gating rather my
content there are perks to the patreon
there's a uh patreon exclusive Discord
uh you get to see the docket for what
I'm working on uh at the start of each
month um you get to well obviously you
get to comment you get to contact me
about stuff if you have direct questions
there are polls for um if I'm
considering a few different ideas there
are perks but actual content I have
never want that to be gated but I've had
to I now effectively have to gate a
director's cut of this
video because the
BBC I don't know what and YouTube is a
terrible system and like YouTube is
legit bad like these are very simple to
fix problems this should not be
difficult to be able to edit those
tracks separately but they don't
implement it and they won't because they
don't have to because they're
effectively Monopoly I can't rely some
on going somewhere else and making the
revenue that I make on YouTube so I'm
stuck here regardless of how bad it is
now I know that some people are no doubt
going to go on the thing well I bet you
they're doing it because of the warning
you have in front of your videos and the
notice that you make about the BBC News
and the transphobia and here's the thing
I still don't believe that to be the
case I'm pretty positive it wasn't the
case the last time because as I said
that was an automated systems issue uh
when they blocked one before while I
don't know why this time happened unless
it starts happening to my other videos
about Doctor Who unless it start unless
this becomes a regular problem
something that they do
repeatedly I'm still disinclined to
think that this is targeted because of
my criticism of the BBC as an overall
organization and in particular its news
arm if they wanted to Target me because
of that they wouldn't be doing it on
just one video and more to the point if
they actually wanted to hurt me they
would have done it on the more recent
videos I've had two review videos for
Doctor Who go up since this and they
ignored those and went after this one
which had already peaked and was largely
done accumulating whatever number of
views it was going to get it was going
to be a drip feed from here on out so no
I don't think that's what's going on if
I start dealing with this problem on a
bunch of other Doctor Who reviews yeah
sure I'll put that on the table and
consider maybe that's what they're doing
but I don't like to be conspiratorially
minded and as angry as I can get I try
not to hold um unfounded grudges or an
unfounded level of bitterness I don't
believe I am targeted if I ever have
actual reason to believe that trust me
I'll say it but I don't I don't think
the BBC knows or cares about what I
do I just don't I don't have an
explanation as to why this happened
unlike the last time it did where I have
what I feel is a I feel very conf
confident is an accurate guess of what
happened there this time I don't know I
don't freaking
know
but this as I said is mostly here just
to explain why that video is now in the
Hacked up and emaciated Condition it's
currently in because I had to cut nearly
25% of that video that video was over 41
minutes now it's just under
so
yeah I just needed to vent a little bit
about that and give an explanation for
the state of the thing if I could have
inserted something at the front end uh
of that and be like hey here's why it's
like that I would have done that but
again the uh editing capabilities of the
back end of YouTube are
minor there isn't a lot you can add it's
basically built around subtracting stuff
because it was pretty much
built uh to theoretically deal with
copyright stuff oh look we'll just cut
out the bit that's that had the
copyright claim and then we'll leave
your video alone which I mean that's
more than we used to have I'll grant you
that but the tools are deeply
inefficient especially since they seem
to operate on the premise that well if
you have a video you must be using the
audio no no no no a lot of it was me
talking my voice and while I wouldn't
have loved it happening on a black
screen I would have preferred that to
what it now is where 25% of my thoughts
are just
gone cuz I did my best to try and leave
it in a state that is more or less
coherent so there were entire segments I
had to cut out where no the the segment
that I C wasn't all footage but where
maybe introducing the thought was done
underneath some footage so now
explaining what I'm even talking about
is gone so I can't just leap into the
middle of the thought or maybe my
concluding thought is gone so I would
have to remove that whole section when I
say 25% is gone that doesn't mean that
25% of the video had footage from the
episode that means that in order to make
something even vaguely approaching
coherent and it's barely that at this
point I had to cut that much to not only
remove the footage but to cut around
whatever now made no sense because
whatever I was saying during bits with
footage was
gone so there we go I rambled on a
little longer than I meant to but this
was just an update and yeah BBC is a
pain in my butt and it is exacerbated by
insufficient and broken systems at
YouTube I'm not here to defend the BBC
they're a pain in my rear end and they
are more than happy to abuse the
copyright system that YouTube has in
place as are many copyright holders but
uh YouTube also just has a busted ass
system that they are big enough that
they don't have to make it better there
isn't really a reasonable competitor so
I'm stuck with it
anyways how's how's
your uh New Year going so far I say that
I might actually get this out uh the day
before the new year well how
how how did your 2023 wrap up because
this was
mine I spent three days fixing this
fixing
whatever anyways whatever your thoughts
are on any of this drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills and is now the
only place where you can see the
original version of that video I'm sorry
that that's the case but it is even if
you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe they all are helpful but
don't worry too much about it what I
really want you to remember is that you
are
beautiful you're valid you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and dealing with
the BS and until next time this council
is
[Music]
adjourned time for me to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin Moore
Zubin Lula goddess ala Oliver be to rock
the thing that goes going in the anime
Ruth goes with the gazarian solitary
pictures rri bugden geek filter Linda
Walters toku BL huan Jen a Kate 808
Becky Sparks rabi likes the poodle Robin
Powell t love Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall white bearish Roslin Bennett
pal baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and Mirra G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just just didn't just didn't I just
didn't do a thing this time but now I've
told you that I didn't do a thing so
I've made a thing about there being no
okay thanks for sticking around
bye